hi
my name is cliff hastings and welcome to
my basement
as well as this presentation it's an
overview of
wolframalpha notebook edition and using
it both
on the desktop and on the cloud
so again my name is cliff let me share
my screen real quick today's uh
presentation will be a co-presentation
between myself
and my co-author of the book hands-on
start the wolf from alpha notebook
edition
uh kelvin misho i'm going to give you a
brief overview of how to use wolfram
alpha notebook edition
and then kelvin will give you a lot more
of the details
uh some of the intricacies of using it
uh separate than just
the very basics so let's click on a new
notebook now you can use notebook
edition
in either the cloud or the desktop again
i'm using it in the cloud for use on a
chromebook or ipad or or whatever
but i can usually use the desktop
version on my laptop
as well so either one is perfectly fine
with the software you get both
now in wolfram alpha notebook edition um
one of the
the great attributes is this is a
notebook so you can save this document
you can intermingle text and
calculations and graphics so i'm going
to call this my first
presentation i can make then a
section cell we'll call this working
with
numbers and we're ready to go so you'll
notice this equal sign with this orange
box around it this is the compute
input we're ready to compute something i
don't need to type anything
complex i can just type whatever it is
i'm doing
hit the enter key at the end and i get
my results
uh if i want to say find 3 4 as
a decimal we can do that too i don't
need to know any sort of language i just
type what i think
what happens is then
this uh wolf from alpha notebook edition
is sending
my calculation to the wolfram servers it
is taking my input
trying to figure out then a wolfram
language equivalent of that
and then so i can calculate it and
provide me that results
so if i say what is eighty percent of
eighty percent
again i don't need to know any language
i just type what i think and then it
provides me
that uh final results
we can do things like what is the square
root
of 256 that should give me a result
of 16 so i typed the word square root of
256
or i can also use a special character's
keyboard where i can just click and type
what it is that i'm interested in
finding as well
so if i do up here click on square root
and 25 hit enter then i should get the
result of five
which i do so there's some nice
characters to point and click uh in this
thing also
uh let's say i want to find i want to
ask
this a question so i'll say is 555
a prime number so in this case i won't
get an
answer of a number i'll get an answer of
true or false
and in this case the answer is false or
if i say
show me the 43rd prime number
then wolfram alpha notebook edition will
get that and return that for me
or i can even find a list and say find
me the list
of the first 50 uh
prime numbers and it should give me that
list now if you've used wolfram alpha
before a lot of what i'm doing so far
you can do in wolf from alpha
but there's a couple of really nice
attributes to the software one
again i'm making a document or a
notebook that i can save and refer back
to
or i can make this a class lecture or a
quiz or a test
and provide this to the students as well
number two in wolf from alpha you can do
single step calculations but in wolfram
alpha notebook edition you can actually
do multi-step
calculations so if i say total that
this means take the previous output find
the sum or the total
and and give me that result so that's
really nice to do multiple step
things and then we'll have wolfen alpha
notebook edition remember
previous outputs that you can refer to
and do calculations with
as well if i do something like let's do
the absolute
oh i'm in all caps that's fine it
doesn't really matter i'll just keep it
to show you
i can use caps lock if i want it does
the same thing
so here's the absolute value of negative
5 or i can use the keyboard
elements to find an absolute value so
i'll say what's the absolute value
of negative 5 plus five and i should get
a result
of 10.
uh let's do another new section so let's
start with
um uh let's see let's do
how about some variables so i'll just
say i'll just type variables here
and i'll say um if a is three
or sorry if a equals three
what is three a plus five and that
answer should be 14
which it is but now because i can do
multiple steps in wolfram alpha noble
condition it remembers what a
is so if i say what's a minus
4 i should get an answer of negative 1.
if i don't want to remember what a is
any longer i can just clear the value of
a
it is now gone and i can do something
like
uh the quadratic formula where i say
solve a
um x squared plus
b x plus
c equals zero for
x and now that a is no longer remembered
and i get that back as the quadratic uh
results
uh let's do another uh solve
uh let's do solve of three x plus
five y equals fifteen
and x equals three
so what is that well x is 3 obviously
and y is 6 fifths
now a neat thing for this is what if i
want to see
the steps of this calculation i can
click on step-by-step solution
and then it's going to walk me through
the steps of finding this
uh calculation so step one solve for y
so 5y plus 9 equals 15
i want to show the next step and it says
isolate the terms with y to the
left-hand side
we'll show the next step again and i
subtract 9 from both sides
as part of that step etc so i can walk
through
all the steps or each step piece by
piece
and it'll teach me how then to do this
calculation
to get to a final answer of y equals
six-fifths
so again another really nice attribute
of wolfram alpha notebook edition
the show steps for calculations helps
immensely with the teaching
in both the classroom setting as well as
just me for a hobbyist who likes to
play around and plunk and learn math
it's going to help teach me that
not just find me the answers as well
let's find let's take a look at some
graphics let's say
let's take a look at negative 5 and 3 on
a number line
and actually i'm going to make a new
section so we call this
graphics
and we'll see this uh number line plot
that it gave me
uh let's take a look at uh let's see
how about graph um of
two three so we can see a single point
on a lot on a
on a graphic or we can actually
visualize
or you can call it graph or plot or
whatever you want it doesn't matter
i'm just going to take a look at a few
points so 0 0
1 2 2 5 and how about 3
9 to finish this so we can visualize
those points
on a set of axes so anyway nice and easy
working with graphics we can uh do
something a little more complex like
like uh functions so we can say you know
visualize
sine of x over x and it'll immediately
do that for us
just like if you've had experience in
mathematica it would in mathematica
or wool from alpha but again we are
being able to create and utilize
all this stuff in a notebook interface
so we can save it
for future calculations and then you'll
also notice this nice little
suggestions bar at the bottom so if you
want to say oh i want to add filling to
this thing how do i do it
just click add fill it'll do that for
you and it'll teach you how to do that
as part of wolfram language as well
last thing real quick is just taking a
look at working with money so if i say
five dollars minus two dollars and 52
cents
that's a very simple calculation to do
and we get that
uh results but it give me back in sense
maybe i want to convert to actual
dollars instead
so again i can use that toolbar to
convert it and i get a result
of two dollars and 48 cents so working
with uh units is very simple two and
wolf from alpha notebook edition so
overall i just wanted to show
i didn't show a lot of power a lot of
complexity just a lot of easy examples
to hopefully convince you and show you
what a great piece of software wolf from
alpha notebook edition is
for the high school and junior college
and even
things like college algebra at the
university level
but also then for hobbyists and people
just
like me that likes to play with math and
learn math that
may not be a programming expert either
so let me go ahead and now hand this
over to kelvin he'll walk you through
some other things in wolfram alpha
notebook edition
and i appreciate you joining me
hi my name is calvin mitchell as cliff
mentioned i'm the co-author of the
hands-on start to wolfram alpha notebook
edition
book i'm going to talk about some of the
additional functionality to do a series
of calculations
and to do that really easily and then
i'm going to talk about
sharing projects and how to run a class
with wolframalpha notebook edition
so let me share my screen here
okay so we just saw cliff do a first
series of calculations and he did that
within a browser
uh wolfram alpha notebook edition can
also be installed locally
one thing that is nice about a local
installation
and something that i'm going to use here
today is
if you go to new and presenter notebook
that gives you a nice slideshow mode
where you can step through content and
you can do live calculations
but it's really nice for lecture formats
so keep in mind as i scroll through
these slides that's how i created this
uh and i'm going to start the
presentation here so you can
see what this looks like let me
toggle full screen okay
so uh in that vein uh
cliff and i have now both shown you
wolfram alpha notebook
notebook edition uh in browser and
locally
uh as a high level comment notebooks and
the functionality
look and work exactly the same in either
so that makes it very nice if you're
sharing projects or
other people are picking up a project
and maybe you're on windows and they're
on mac
or you're on a chromebook and they're on
a windows machine
a notebook is a notebook so that's very
nice i think often times in
academia maybe every student in a class
is
issued a chromebook so maybe they all
have the same
hardware anyway but in a bring your own
device scenario or
in a case where you're just not sure
what kind of device
they might be using it's really nice to
just know that
there's nothing extra to remember there
next thing i want to cover is again
little tips on creating a series of
calculations
um i'll run one of these in the local
wolfram alpha notebook edition where
this is very as i said similar to the
look and feel for
uh how you know how cliff was creating
calculations and
how these things look in browser and i'm
going to click over to
uh just to do a compare contrast
so one thing though that's nice to
create a series of calculations
is if you do a calculation and you want
to reference the last result
so here we've done an integral and maybe
we want to graph that
you can literally use the term that
or result to reference the previous
result
so when i say graph that that i get
exactly the graph that that i intended
to get there
which is pretty nice the other thing
is there's a button here called related
computations
and so related to this integral uh this
is a nice
series of suggestions for things that
the software does really well
and certainly you can try things and the
way to state calculations in everyday
english
encourages you to try things but in this
case it just gives you a list of helpful
things like
if i want to do a plot of the function
and the integral when i click that
button a new
input cell is created here a new
calculation
as well as a new result or if i click
something like
limit at x equals zero again another
calculation is started
and another result is displayed so as i
click that
it just again builds on the series of
calculations
and it does it really quick and really
easily which is nice
next thing i want to talk about is
special characters
so you can state calculations in
everyday english
but there are cases where you might want
to mirror a textbook with a
integral symbol or greek characters or
infinity
you can enter any of these characters
with this palette here at the top
right called enter special characters
when you click that it brings up this
system of buttons here
and you just click on these to insert
them in a calculation so that's how i'm
doing all of these
uh all these three calculations the
integral comes out just the same as
above
the limit is returned and calculated
uh you know with infinity and with greek
characters
or we can do pi to a thousand digits and
instead of writing out
pi in in everyday english maybe capital
pi
uh then we can just use the symbol there
so that's very nice as well to mirror a
textbook
next i want to elaborate on step by step
solutions a little bit
so if you start with a calculation
like solving an equation
related not related similar to the
related calculations there is a
step-by-step solution button that you
can click on
if there are step-by-step solutions
built in just like
related calculations that makes a new
calculation
with instead of just the result it gives
you all the step-by-step solutions
and you can either toggle through those
one at a time or show
all the steps and so if you want to quiz
yourself
the one at a time is nice if you just
want to check a result
the show all steps is nice but i think
in general this is a nice way to figure
out
if you're working on a problem set did
you make a arithmetic error at the end
or did you make a mistake at the
beginning and you really need to go back
and
read the chapter over again and make
sure that you're clear on the concepts
but in a case where
you're working individually maybe it's
outside of class time or it's at two in
the morning
having this real time feedback is is
very very handy
the step-by-step solutions though uh
spans all common math topics
so that can be uh uh
pre-college you know k-12 topics uh
mostly high school topics
but it can also be undergraduate topics
you know things like calculus
um the other nice thing too is if you do
something like show steps of an integral
uh the integral or the steps are
explained
and it mirrors a very common you know a
typical common textbook
explanation so if the solution involves
u substitution
or the chain rule or something like that
the steps go through and explain it
uh you know it with that that wording
and with that methodology in mind
i'll do one last one here where we do a
derivative and it's the same workflow
where it goes through the steps
goes through hints you can look at them
one at a time or you can see them all
so as students are working through this
in
you know maybe an algebra class they
know what to expect when they get to an
algebra 2 class or
calculus class or something like that
and it can help them throughout their
academic career
last thing on this slide that i want to
talk about is graphics and animations
so you can do uh all sorts of graphics
like
graph 3x plus 5 or graph 3x plus 10 but
if you want to do something like graph
three x
plus b varying b from minus five to five
so instead of one specific graph i wanna
look at the overall concept here i wanna
look at what happens when i change b
and what effect does that have on the
graph when you use that term
varying uh by default there are sliders
then that are drawn
and so as i move b uh
into the negatives and i've got the i've
got the size
uh very blown up here for the sake of
the presentation today but
uh as i move b here you can see that
uh the you know i can see the
y-intercept here
and i can see how that uh relates to the
original equation
or i can zoom in or zoom out with the um
you know the range of the domain of the
plot so in general though this is a nice
way
instead of looking at one plot or you
know recalculating plots a bunch of
times
this is a good way to look at overall
concepts and that term
varying is a very flexible thing that
you can use throughout mathematics
to do these kind of examples that have
animations and
mouse-driven sliders
all right the next thing i want to talk
about is
sharing courseware or sharing a finished
project
in wolfram alpha notebook edition we
call that publishing a notebook
so if you want to share a project where
people can immediately read it
and see it you can publish a notebook
and that creates a second url
that anyone can look at and anyone can
read through these examples
so if i take this um this example that i
was working on here
if i click the publish drop down menu i
can give it a name
i can password protect it but when i
click publish
i get a second url and then this is a
uh you know a preview slide where
everybody can see what i'm doing
if they want to read this idea that i've
outlined you know anyone in the world
can read this
this notebook and take a look i just
need to
post this somewhere or send them the url
now in a class setting if you want the
students to make their own notes
so maybe you're sharing a lecture and
you want them to take notes at the same
time
or you're sharing an assignment where
you want them to adapt
a calculation but the bulk of the
document is their work
uh students can either click on make
your own copy
or download and then that makes a second
copy where
you know if 30 30 students click on that
uh they each get their own copy
they're they're each working in their
own copy of the document
you know they're not affecting the
author's copy so it's really good for
assignments and it's really good for
you know lectures where students need to
jump off and
use that as a jumping off point
basically
all right i want to wrap up here with a
little bit on professional development
and implementation uh there are several
training resources that i've linked here
and we'll have this notebook posted
somewhere uh but the main one that
cliff and i have been putting a lot of
effort in is the hands-on start to
wolfram
alpha notebook edition book so this is
just now wrapped up
just now being released it's been a big
project for both of us
this is useful for a couple reasons
first
is it can just be a really good source
of tutorials
if you are new to the software and you
need tutorials works great
if your students are new to it and you
want to pick out a couple
uh tutorials and have them work through
it or maybe you want to adopt it as the
textbook for your class
it's really nice for that we've gone
through pretty quickly here how to make
notebooks and make calculations
you know the book has a much more
deliberate uh structure where things are
explained in a lot more detail
a lot of the variations are explained in
a lot more detail
um it just it just slows down a little
bit and
it explains all the variations or why
you would want to do some of these
things
in the first place um the second part of
the book
is examples and they're broken down uh
by course so if you're teaching a
particular class
you've got a really good source for
ready-made examples
where if you're in an algebra class and
you're teaching
expanding polynomials or something like
that you can just grab the examples
immediately
and then maybe use some verbatim maybe
swap in the
equations or examples from your lesson
plan maybe swap in the equations from
your textbook but
it acts as a really good jumping off
point if you need
ready-made examples and again if you're
going to use them verbatim great if
you're going to adapt them great
they're useful in either case
and while we're talking about this book
i'll just show a couple
screenshots of the book you're looking
at a pdf copy but
it'll look the same in print uh or in
the kindle store
um this first chapter um the book starts
with a couple sample projects
so before we get into teaching the
software itself we outline
you know what's possible after you
understand the software
so something like having a summer job
and figuring out how much money you'd
save over the summer
that involves some data you know what is
the minimum wage in a certain state
it involves dates you know how many
weekdays are there in the summer
it involves a bit of algebra some
graphing maybe we want to
resolve this based on some different
starting point conditions but it's just
a good way to figure out
you know what would a project in this
software look like
second chapter goes through and shows
how to create quizzes and tests
especially if they're going to be shared
in print form so if you want to do
something like
create auto-numbered questions with
nicely typeset formulas
you know we explain that in a lot more
detail in that chapter as well
and then i'll skip ahead to chapter 12.
so this is one of the chapters where
if you're teaching algebra this gives
you a bunch of ready-made examples for
algebra
uh things like expanding polynomials
factoring polynomials uh showing the
steps
building up a series of calculations um
you know different algebraic
manipulations things like
graph that where x goes from -10 to 10
so these are all just very good little
tips that you can grab
they're things that are will immediately
work and things that the software is
immediately good at
uh but it saves you the process of
experimenting or building your own
lesson plans necessarily
you can use your existing lesson plans
and then just grab
you know maybe a half a dozen
calculations or dozen calculations
you know throughout the course of the
algebra uh term or the algebra semester
um you know you can grab as you need
basically
okay so we'll post this notebook i won't
go through the rest of this in too much
detail but
we've got uh documentation we've got
training videos
uh so this is a video where cliff goes
through and builds a first
notebook but you can watch it on demand
so either that's useful for instructors
or it's great for students
we've got how to's that you can read
through how to do things
like make a slideshow or something like
that we've got some very drilled in
sample courseware so maybe some ideas on
how do you lay out a lecture how do you
lay out a student project
how could that look or what what's a
good format to follow for that
we're also trying to do as much
customized training as possible
so if you're at a school and all the
instructors are brand new to the
software
you know we're we're trying to do as
much support as we can where
maybe a dedicated hour and everyone
builds their own first
lesson plan you get tips from us
training from us
q a from us uh we're trying to do as
much of that as possible
so if any or all of that interests you
you know drop us a line
uh but i'll i will wrap there and uh
thanks for attending today
so it seems like we've kept up with the
questions uh in the chat pod so far
and uh we've run a little bit long so uh
for
more q a and for more questions we'll
put cliff's
email in the chat pod and probably mine
as well
and just drop us a line email us we can
talk offline if you have more questions
but thanks again for attending
you